YURI GRINSHTEYN: Welcome to
Cloud OnAir, our live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday,
and we're really happy
to have you here with us.
My name is Yuri Grinshteyn.
I'm a customer engineer
here at Google Cloud.
And I'm incredibly happy
and excited to have
Carter Maslan, the founder and
CEO of Camio with us today.
Carter, thank you so
much for being here.
CARTER MASLAN: I'm
happy to be here.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
We'll have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
We'll also be doing a live
Q&A later in the program.
So first of all, Carter,
again thank you for being here
and congratulations on
your Best of CS award.
CARTER MASLAN: Thank you.
Just extremely
excited about that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Great.
So today we'll be
talking about how
you have built Camio
to provide machine
learning for video
intelligence to your customers.
So perhaps we just
start by you telling us
the problem you
set out to solve.
CARTER MASLAN: So Camio is
real time video search that
works with any camera stream.
And the big problem
with video today
is that in recording
hours and hours of video,
there's only a certain
small fraction of it
that's actually warranting
any attention from humans.
And so getting machines
to do that work for you
to highlight what's
interesting is the core
of what Camio is about.
So that real time video
search will automatically
identify the few
two minutes perhaps
each out of every day that
is warranting your attention.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So why don't we have you
show us exactly what this
looks like in practice.
CARTER MASLAN: That'd be good.
We'll jumped to a demo where
I can just do a quick search.
And I'll just start by
looking at a single camera
like Liverpool, which is a
public library in New York.
And the first thing to notice is
that there's no dead air time,
so the first level
of machine learning
is just highlighting
interesting events
that warrant your attention
over a large period of time.
But you can do quick
searches like this.
I can just say I'm looking
for people in red or blue
on the sidewalk, and now out
of two- or three-week period,
I'm seeing every time
there was a person that
was either in red or blue
across the sidewalk including
a quick chart for the frequency.
You can just see this is all
the times that people in blue,
all the times people in red
are-- all the time that there
were people period.
And that same thing applies--
you can still play the
video behind the event,
but you can also do
advanced searches
like if I only want
to see when there were
bikes across all the cameras.
You could just type
in bikes, and now this
is using CNN's to label
the events for the cases
where there was a bike.
And like I said
before, you can play
even this person that's
dedicated in winter time snow
biking.
It'll find that.
You can also do a quick
search for something
as advanced as snow plow.
So I'll just do a quick search.
Snowplow for that same period.
And so this is just
a quick example.
All these demos are things that
you can open in your browser
and do yourself
at Camio.com/demo.
There's a sequence
of links that you
can open without
any kind of auth
and follow along as we do demos
throughout this discussion.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
Thank you.
So that looks really cool
and really impressive.
You're able to very quickly
find interesting things
in these videos, and
the UI is really fast.
And it looks like it can
provide a lot of value.
Can you give us a sense of
who might actually use this?
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah.
So anybody that has cameras,
large corporate campuses,
cities, even homes are using it.
But it's basically--
the core value of Camio
is that it can work
with video streams
from old camera
systems, existing camera
systems, your
existing DVR, or NVR,
and make it into
something that's
smart and searchable and
browsable so that it learns
what you find interesting in
each individual camera stream.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
All right so let's go back to
our content and resume there.
And I think the next thing our
audience would very much like
to understand is some
of the decisions that
went into building Camio.
And first you know why did
you choose to build it on GCP?
CARTER MASLAN: Well, we--
our founders came
from Google, so we
were familiar with
that at the beginning.
But the core reason
that we chose GCP
was the dynamic scalability
and quick deployment time.
So we deployed
several times a day.
And as a startup,
your core advantage
is just listening to what
customers want and delivering
it quickly and to be able to hit
the deploy button several times
a day without the hassles of
any kind of hardware issues
or maintenance issues.
That was a big one.
But then the core of
the problem is just
matched to the dynamic scaling.
So this chart--
I don't know if you can present
this chart of a real life
deployment with 62 cameras
that shows the number of events
over the time of day, and you
can see that it's very spiky.
It's five times the traffic
during a daytime shopping
mall versus the nighttime.
And when you have that kind of
a problem where you're saying,
well, tell me what's interesting
out of hours of video
with this kind of
spiky activity level,
having the dynamic provisioning
automatically scale
your compute resources to
match what you're analyzing
is a key strength.
So rather than having to
deal with on-site, on-premise
hardware that has to be
provisioned at peak capacity,
you can instead provision at a
much lower dynamic rate that's
much more cost efficient and
much more bandwidth efficient.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, I think you
make a really
important point here
is that it would be really
difficult to achieve
optimization using any kind
of a traditional on-premise
infrastructure with a
workload and a demand that
looks like this.
This is incredibly spiky.
Like you said, I think you're
delta between your baseline
here and your peak is--
it looks to be at
least 5x if not more.
CARTER MASLAN: Right.
You have some
cameras that might be
like a mechanical
room or a server room
where credit card data
is processed where
there's very low activity.
And then you've got others
that are like the main entrance
for a shopping mall.
And so it's not
just hour of day,
but it's by the
venue of the camera.
And so making that
cost efficient
is the core focus is how do
you take the mass of millions
of existing cameras
and connect them
to state of the art machine
learning at a price point that
makes sense for people on
a business perspective.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Makes a lot of sense.
So this looks
really interesting.
Let's move on to how
this actually works.
So it looks like there's really
four major components to Camio.
There's the customer's
on-premise infrastructure,
which is what they need
to collect the video
and send it to the
cloud for processing.
There's all this stuff
that happens in the cloud.
There's the user experience,
which is delivered
via web and native mobile apps.
And then there are
the hook [INAUDIBLE],,
which we'll cover
a bit later on.
So let's first start by talking
about what does the customer--
viewers need to really do this.
We'll start with the cameras.
I think you said this
already that they
can use their existing
cameras as well as new ones,
but are these special
purpose cameras
or can they just be any camera?
CARTER MASLAN: They can
literally be any camera.
The nice thing is that Camio
analyzes the H.264 video
stream itself that comes
from the camera directly
or from a network video
recorder like a DVR
or a video management
system, a VMS.
And so no matter
where it comes from,
your existing cameras,
even analog cameras
that are connected
through one of those NVRs
can be accessed via Camio.
So in terms of a
customer's deployment,
they can light up
their existing cameras
in less than 10
minutes because as long
as the cameras are on a network.
That's all that's needed.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So then the second part of
their on-premise infrastructure
would be the network video
recorder or video management
systems.
So, one, is that a required
component, and, two,
how does that system
really play into this?
CARTER MASLAN: So the
network video recorder or VMS
is usually used to provide the
complete archive of HD video
on site, on premise.
So you can either use that
or go direct to the cloud.
You can choose.
So it becomes mainly
an issue of what's
your uplink bandwidth, what
are your archiving retention
requirements and things.
But you're free to serve the
video streams from the NVR
or from the camera.
It doesn't matter which.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Very cool.
And then the third part of
their on-premise deployment
is this thing that's
just called box.
Well, that sounds
awfully mysterious.
Can you tell us a bit
about what the box is?
CARTER MASLAN: Yes.
The box is a video gateway.
It's basically a device that
analyzes the video streams
on the local network.
So you get a huge
bandwidth efficiency gain
because all of the analysis
and metadata that's
observed about each
12-second video event
is analyzed locally by the box.
And the box is in this
kind of chatty conversation
with the cloud saying, hey,
do you find this interesting?
Based on what you've
seen the user do,
do you think the
user wants this?
And all of those decisions
in that chatty conversation
are determining what
happens subsequently
in analyzing the video.
And that's where the
big cost efficiencies
come from because
you saw the spikes.
If a camera is--
even with high activity,
if only a fraction of it
is interesting, like when a
person approaches the server
room that houses your
credit card, data that's
when you want HD recording with
full analysis and integration
with their security
operations center and things.
So all of those
kinds of decisions
are made locally by the machine
learning that's running on box.
And we'll talk about later what
machine learning unbox does,
but the second thing that box
does is gives you security.
So you remember the Mari virus?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: I do.
CARTER MASLAN: So that
was a massive attack
that was using people's cameras
and DVRs, the vulnerability
in them, because the traditional
deployment model for cameras
on corporate campuses
and things for when
you need remote viewing was
to forward inbound ports.
And since box is only
over SSL port 443,
you can completely
close your local network
to inbound network requests.
So in addition to its
efficiency function,
there's also a really
good security function
because you can now
close all inbound ports
on your local networks to avoid
a repeat of the Mari virus.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
All right, so we've
got our cameras.
They're capturing
all this video.
We have their NVR or VMS that's
archiving all the HD video.
And we have the box that's
basically efficiently choosing
which bits to actually send
from the cloud for processing.
So which takes us
to the part that I
think most folks online are here
to actually see, which is what
are you doing in the cloud.
So let's move into that.
Let's cover three major
paths that I think
are going to be interesting
to our audience.
First is what you're doing with
that video when it arrives.
The second one will be how
you were delivering that user
experience.
You showed us the UI.
It's incredibly fast.
It's very responsive, and it's
operating on obviously what
are fairly complex datasets.
So I'd love to hear about
how you're really making
that as performant as it is.
And then thirdly
we'll talk about how
you're taking both the videos
data as well as the user
interaction data and combining
them to power your ML.
That's sound good?
CARTER MASLAN: That sounds good.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So let's
talk about the video first.
You've got your cameras.
You've got your box.
Box sends video to the cloud.
What happens then?
CARTER MASLAN: So
as I mentioned,
there's a front end
that's basically
in that chatty
conversation with the box.
And so we use App
Engine Standard
as that front end for
the dynamic scaling
and responsiveness to both
APIs, queries, and end
user search API queries.
And so that is the
initial entry point
is the Google front end that's
talking to an App Engine
Standard set of instances.
And then those decisions
made at the beginning
based on the trained
models to that point
determine all the
subsequent workflow
that you see on the
right side of this chart.
So what level of
analysis should get--
should be applied to this?
Where should the storage go?
So if you want to just
have a response that says,
hey, for this video, send
it to Nearline Storage
because it's unlikely
to be reviewed.
So for cost efficiency, just
let me give you a sign GCS URL
and just send it
straight to GCS versus
this is an important event, so
lets call hooks that are things
like the Google Vision API or
other specialized classifiers
because this is
particularly important.
All of that workflow
is determined
after it goes
through the front end
with these dynamically
provisioned App Engine Standard
instances.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
it makes a lot of sense
that you're using App
Engine Standard because
of the big spikiness that
you have in your traffic.
That's a textbook use for--
use case for App Engine when
you have very unpredictable
workloads, very
spiky workloads, App Engine can
scale as high as it needs to.
It can scale down as low as
it needs to all the way to 0,
although obviously
with cameras sources
you probably never quite at 0.
But it certainly
makes a lot of sense
that you're using
App Engine that way.
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah.
For the people that are opening
the demo page, Camio.com/demo,
your queries are spinning
up instances in response
to your individual queries
because there's a mismatch out
of the workload for recording
and analyzing video versus
querying video because
you do much less querying.
So there's also the
dynamic provisioning
based on you guys going
to the website right now
and doing your own searches.
Those are spinning up
instances to make sure you
get good response times.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So that helps us understand
what you're doing with a video
as it comes from the platform.
Now let's talk about all those
users out there that are again
going to Camio.com/demo and
actually trying this out
for themselves.
How are you delivering
that experience?
CARTER MASLAN: So there's
a front-end query parser
that determines based on what's
observed in your camera feeds
what you're asking for.
So when you do a search like
Toyota Prius yesterday 1:00 PM,
it's parsing that, and it
knows that Toyota Prius
is make and model
of a car that you're
looking for in your feed.
So the first step is just
understanding your query,
and that language has some
natural language processing
of the query itself.
So you can say you know one
day ago at noon and also terms
and labels that are
applicable to your cameras.
And that's all served
from data store.
So data store is indexed based
on both the time, the camera
source, the user, all that
stuff, to make it fast
and searchable.
And the video itself is served
from Google Cloud Storage.
And in the process
of taking in video,
there's a whole
bunch of workflows
that are triggered from both
cloud data flow and just task
cues and Pub/Sub that
are triggered based
on the content of the video.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
So that's actually
I think an interesting point.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
you're using App Engine
task queues and data flow,
and what of the two things that
you're achieving with those?
CARTER MASLAN: I guess on the
task queue front, the big value
that we actually didn't
anticipate when we first
started using task queue is
was just how resilient it is,
and we learned some--
in terms of if you have
a temporary Memcache
failure or a temporary
data store failure,
they're seamless to the users.
There's no impact
because it gets retried,
and it's a really
nice mechanism to have
communication among modules
and versions of your app.
So in our case, our application
is split with a lot in Python
and a lot of the
front end in Java.
We have modules that have
different kinds of workloads,
and task queues are easy way to
coordinate functions among them
reliably without any risk
of loss of data or loss
of the request.
The same thing with Pub/Sub.
We use Pub/Sub for simple things
like if a batch operation is
completed, somebody might have
created a time lapse let's say.
So they may have said give
me a time lapse of my camera
from 8 AM Monday to 5 PM
Friday on a construction site.
When that's completed,
we'll use Pub/Sub just
to notify people
of the completion,
including our internal
processes that
will do the billing and stuff.
So it's just been a really
good, flexible mechanism
to coordinate
communication across all
the different modules
and application versions.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
you're using task queues
to do some of that
orchestration between modules.
You're using Pub/Sub to do
some of that communication
and things like notifications
or sent using Pub/Sub.
What's the role of data
flow in this architecture?
CARTER MASLAN: We're mainly
using the mappers for data
flow, not so much
the reducing, but we
do do periodic
summaries of counters
because Camio is all based
on usage based billing.
So data flow helps us go over
massive amounts of events.
Each camera-- each
day there's millions
of events to be summarized.
How many megabytes
have been uploaded?
How many important events?
How many unimportant events?
All of those things are
done via data flow including
the triggers to manage billing
cycles and things that are
driven off of those counters.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So now we've covered what
you're doing with the video
as it comes in from the
camera through the box
and is ingested.
We've covered what you're
doing to provide that user
experience in the UI.
Tell me how you're
combining those two data
sources to actually do machine
learning in the platform?
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah.
That's the key thing is
that the neural nets that
are being trained are on
a camera specific basis.
So on the box itself,
there is something
that we call internally
adaptive motion filtering, which
is a set of neural nets
that are all concurrently
competing to be
right about what's
interesting for that
particular camera.
And the tricky thing in
cameras is that it's not just
about eliminating spurious
pixel motion because there
are a lot of times where
a scene has something
that is a real object moving,
but it's just not interesting.
You could have in the front of
a commercial building entrance
a tree that has just
a blowing branch that
is just swaying periodically.
It is a real object moving,
but it's not interesting.
And so the box itself
has neural nets
that are learning that
that swing branch is not
interesting.
But then the feedback
loops that come
from you using the products.
So when you play an event or
you share an event or you save
an event or you give it
an explicit thumbs up
or thumbs down like
you're rating songs,
those all are now
collected training feedback
for your individual camera.
So even though
there's no visibility
into what your camera's
actually observing,
it still can train
itself based on the way
that you use the product.
And so those things surface in
the clean summary of your video
and the precision of
the search results.
But also in some
efficiency things.
So I was going to show one
example of that efficiency
part of the machine learning.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, let's do that.
So we'll do one more demo.
CARTER MASLAN: This is a demo
that we call the matrix demo.
And part of the
machine learning is
identifying what is interesting
versus not interesting.
In this case, there's
a lot of passing
street traffic that will be
in low res, fast time lapse.
And then when the person that's
approaching the sidewalk, which
is the nighttime library that
you want to actually observe,
it'll slow down into
full HD recording.
So this is why we call
it the matrix effect
because you'll see the
passing street traffic is
low res, fast time lapse.
And then it slows
down to HD right
as the person comes into view.
So we love that as an
example of machine learning
that is smart enough to
differentiate between passing
street traffic and the
people that you're actually
trying to protect at
night at the library.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah and
that's actually really amazing.
Not only does it
know that something
is happening that's different
than what was happening before,
it's something that
might be interesting.
I now need to provide
additional context around that
and, like you said, give me
that full frame, high definition
feed now.
So someone who is
looking at this video
after the fact can
actually make decisions
around what did they see?
Is it something that they
need to take action with?
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah.
And just from an
economics perspective,
you're saving both bandwidth
and storage and processing costs
by--
this was when we
first started talking,
we were talking about
the power efficiency
of having machine
learning make decisions
on what compute resources are
applied to any particular video
event.
And it's not dissimilar
from some of the things
that I've read on the
machine learning that
did a better job managing
power in Google data centers
than humans.
And so it's similar
for your video
feeds where we're actually
having the machines help
you save bandwidth and
compute costs by knowing
what warrants the extra work.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So now that we've seen the demo,
let's get back to our content
here.
And then next
question I have is now
that we understand what you're
doing with the data in GCP
and we understand some of
the use cases that are there,
quote unquote out of the box,
although not the Camio box,
I imagine you have lots of
customers that come to you
and ask you to do things
that the platform has not
been built to do.
How do you support new use
cases, new classifiers,
new requirements?
CARTER MASLAN: That was one
of the key design criteria
for a cameo is that we wanted
it to be a video processing
pipeline that's
open on both ends.
So not only is it
open to all cameras,
but it's open to all
machine learning classifiers
and third party hooks.
So hooks are the way that Camio
has an extensible pipeline,
and it's been used
for things as funny
as like we had no
classifier for fish faces.
And there was a
cargo competition
to classify yellowfin
tuna versus bluefin
tuna versus marlin and sharks.
And it's as simple as defining
a hook in the Camio pipeline
where you can say when
the fish store opens
or when there's a
human on deck, I
want you to run additional
classifiers that
are smart enough
to differentiate
between types of fish.
And that's not an expertise
we have, but in the old adage
there's more smart people
outside of your company
than in your company.
That's the reason
that we have hooks
is that now all of that grunge
work of getting millions
of cameras connected and
being able to be processed,
they're now accessible
by third parties that
may specialize in
face recognition
whether their fish
is [INAUDIBLE]
or other or access
control systems that
want to be integrated.
All of this is an
extensible thing.
So you just register hook and
do the additional analysis
that you'd like to do.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So hooks are a
great way for folks
to take advantage
of the pipeline
that you've built to do like
you said classification that
isn't there out of the box.
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah.
In this example, this was not
even additional classification.
If you look at
this command, it's
basically just do a
quick walk through.
You're saying when there's
a match on this query--
so it's much like if you've used
Google Alerts search alerts--
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Absolutely.
CARTER MASLAN: It's
the same thing in Camio
when you pin a query that
now becomes an alert.
That's the same thing that
drives the API for hooks.
You basically say whenever
there's people 2:00 AM to 5:00
AM on the rooftop--
this is an example of a query--
do this, which in this
case was a request
to have a call back URL that
would just schedule a guard--
on-premise guard tour.
So now instead of just having
your on-site security staff
roam, you're getting targeted
alerts based on query matches.
So this cruel command, it's
a single simple command that
just says when that
query match happens,
call me back giving me the
payload of which camera source
observed it, what the
earliest and latest time was,
and what we labeled it with.
And now that can drive
your scheduling system
for a guard tour.
It can drive your
notification systems.
It can do anything.
So this is the flexibility
in extending via hooks.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So hooks are a great way to get
additional information that may
not be there out of the box.
How would you go
about understanding
when things are happening.
So example I know
that I saw people
in the rooftop between
the specific hours,
but what if I want to
know exactly when someone
opened that hatch for example
and started climbing up?
How do I go about doing that?
CARTER MASLAN: So there's--
maybe we could look at
annotations quickly.
This is an example where
part of the pipeline
enables you to correlate
any label to a time stamp.
And that means that any
device, whether it's
a door sensor or an
access control bajan,
can now be a source of
annotating a video feed.
So if you want to say
show me every time
that the fish door
was open, it's
simple to see that in video
because this one command just
says put these labels, badge 1,
2, 3 unlocked, as a door unlock
event.
Now whenever you search for show
me the times that this door was
unlocked, you'll see the video
that matches those events that
come from those sensors.
So it's not just about
the video content,
but it's also third-party
devices and sensors
that can be integrated
into that video content.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
So now we've covered hooks
and annotations, which
are which-- ways by which
other people can, again,
take advantage of the platform
and the pipeline you've built.
Thank you so much for that.
Before we get into
the Q&A, I wanted
to ask you one last question.
As you've built out
your infrastructure
and your platform on GCP,
are there any lessons
that you've learned that
you think our audience would
benefit from?
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah.
I think if I were to summarize
some of the top lessons
from the past years of working
with GCP, one of the first ones
is in terms of your data,
if you're using data store,
make sure you think in
terms of key value buckets.
Because if you come from
a relational background,
you may be tempted to just
take your relational thinking
into data store.
And if you want
to avoid problems
with eventual consistency
and indexing update times
and things like that,
think of your data
as atomic key value
buckets rather than
as rows in a relational table.
That's probably one.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah makes sense.
CARTER MASLAN: Two, in
terms of performance,
we found that almost always when
you profile your application
for performance, RPCs,
remote procedure calls,
are the culprit.
So think about how you
do things in parallel.
So if you have a list
of events that you're
going to display on
the screen like you're
seeing with our search
results, do a batch
GET so that you've
got a list of 60 keys
that you're fetching in
one RPC that it can all
be in parallel rather than
doing that sequentially.
So that's another lesson.
I'm trying to think of other
highlights that we've learned.
But those are two
starting points
YURI GRINSHTEYN: No,
those are very good.
And on that second
point, I'll make
a bit of a product
pitch, which is folks
if you're interested
in understanding
the performance of the
RPCs in your application,
take a look at the
trace functionality
within stack driver.
It can really expose
those slow-running RPCs
until you get exactly
where some of the links
in your application
calls may be.
Well, awesome.
Thank you so much.
I think now we will
take a quick break.
Please stay tuned
for the live Q&A,
and we'll be back in
less than one minute.
Welcome back.
Let's go through some of the
questions that you have for us.
Our first question
is, how does Camio
charge its customers given
how much heavy processing
you're doing?
CARTER MASLAN: That's
a great question.
We at one point had started
with a fixed monthly price,
and we realized quickly the
workloads vary so much by what
the camera is observing.
So you can have a really
inexpensive camera
in a quiet server room with
credit card processing data
and a really busy camera
observing a parking garage.
And so we have
usage-based pricing.
So you can pay on a
per gigabyte basis,
and that enables you to
tune the machine learning.
We also wanted to have that
incentive where as it gets
smarter, your prices go down.
And so basically
Camio has custom plans
that our partners
offer that are all
tuned to your specific
video processing
needs including
duration of storage.
Do you need 90-day
storage, a year storage?
What kinds of advanced
analytics do you want?
Do you want card classification
or just OCR text recognition?
What amount of events do you
want processed every day?
All of these things
are variables
that go into the
pricing of a plan
so that you get the
lowest possible price
for your workload.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Great, so it sounds
like the two real
metrics are going
to be how much video
you're processing,
and then the second part is
how complex the processing is.
CARTER MASLAN: Yep.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK.
Great.
All right.
So next question is if I
see something interesting
happen in the feed, how
do I go about sharing
the video to the world.
And is this the same as
traditional video sharing,
or are you doing
something different there?
CARTER MASLAN: It's different
in the sense that our share via
links-- we call
them query links--
when you share a link, it's
like sharing a constrained view
onto a feed that you
can revoke at any time.
So for everybody that's
used Google Docs sharing,
you have an option where
you can either add somebody
as a permanent collaborator,
or you can just send a link.
And so we have that same model.
You can either send
a link with-- so
that when you're doing these
demos on the Camio.com demo
page, that's an
example of query links
because they give you the right
to access the content just
by having the token
that is in that query.
But if you have somebody
that is part of your security
operations staff,
for example, they
may be a permanent
guest on the account,
much like a collaborator
on a document.
But the difference
in Camio's case
is that the sharing
can be constrained
to specific segments.
So it's like if you could
share a Google doc but only
one paragraph of the document.
And I'll give an example
of that if I could do
a demo from a city camera here.
Let me just-- this is an
example of a city camera
that is the last demo
link on the demo page.
And this is only 9:45 to
10:00 AM on last Friday.
And so the interesting thing
is if I try to scroll earlier,
it stops at 9:45 even though
there's a lot of other video.
So this is the example
of sharing a paragraph
within a doc.
But the interesting
thing is I can still
search within that query
link that's shared with me.
So if I want to do
this search, I'll
just say what I was really
looking for is a white Toyota.
Now let me just see
if there was-- there
was no white Toyota
at that point.
So let me just certainly do--
I'll just look for a white car.
And now I'm subsetting
my search to just
be the events that had
a white car in them.
And so you can do the same
thing with a constrained period
of time where I can say I
was just looking for 9:50 AM
to 9:52 AM on Friday.
And now because that is
within the constraints
of the 9:45 to 10:00
sharing, I can still do this.
So if you take a scenario like
the Boston Marathon bombing
where they had 1,000 people
review video for three days
to find the suspects, this
kind of crowdsourced review
gives you a secure way to
share a very limited portion
of your video stream
but enables people
to do certain refinements
and additional queries
within the constraints
of what you've shared.
And you can add--
you can share by link, but you
can also add people to the link
so that they still
have to authenticate.
So there's-- that's the other
level of sharing is even when
you share via link, you can
still additionally require that
somebody be authenticated.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
it sounds like you
have some very powerful
sharing capabilities
both in allowing other folks
to view and collaborate
in the streams but also
control what they can actually
see to control their access
to perhaps specific slices
of time--
CARTER MASLAN: Yeah or zones.
Like you could say
even if they only
see people that are
coming out of an elevator,
you could have a zone
elevator share only that zone
and then they can't see
what's happening over
in another office room.
It would only be
the events that are
intersecting with the elevator.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
I think that also
answers our next question
about that
granularity of access.
I think you've done a
great job of covering that.
So our final question is
actually around the box
believe it or not.
So you're using your gateway
on a site to do pre-processing
and then sending
it to the cloud.
How many parallel streams can
this gateway actually manage?
Or maybe a broader
question is how do you
go about deploying a
system by which there
are many, many, many cameras?
CARTER MASLAN: So
the simple answer
is I could just give
you the rough metrics.
It's because it's dependent
on the streams that
are being monitored.
So if you have 4K streams at 30
frames per second versus 720p
streams at 20 frames per
second, that's a big difference.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: True.
CARTER MASLAN: But
the general point
is that it scales based
on the number of streams
and the characteristics
of the stream.
So to give an example,
just if you just
have three HD 1080p streams
at 30 frames per second,
you can use a tiny little box
that will handle those three.
And then if you go
to six, you can just
linearly stack more boxes.
But you can also run
boxes a virtual machine
on any set of servers.
So if you have 120
cameras on campus,
you can run that on a single
server if it's beefy enough.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Understood.
CARTER MASLAN: So we have
tools that estimate--
you enter in the
characteristics of your stream
like I have 1080p streams at 30
frames per second at this four
megabit encoding rate.
And then it spits out
your recommended number
of boxes based on the number
of CPUs, the number of memory,
and stuff.
So I hate to say it depends,
but it really does depend.
We're trying to make it simple
by using a spreadsheet that
is on our site that will give
you an answer to this question.
It is a help article on how do
I scale to the number of streams
that are monitoring.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Fantastic.
All right, that's all
the questions we had.
Carter, thank you so
much for being here.
Really appreciate it.
Folks on the stream.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
We sincerely hope you have found
this useful and informative.
I think it was a
great way to showcase
some of the really core
capabilities of GCP,
things like auto
scaling and the ability
to ingest these
massive amounts of data
and do some machine
learning processing on them.
Before we sign
off, I want to let
you know that if you've
enjoyed this format,
you should tune
into a more formal--
sorry, a less formal
session that we
run once or twice a week.
It's called the
GCP Online Meetup.
You can find us on Meetup.com
or subscribe to us on YouTube
at YouTube.com/GCPLive.
We'll be signing
off but please stay
tuned for the next session,
Cloud Accelerating Ugle Cloud
Migration, which
will come to you
live from the Google
New York office shortly.
Thank you and have a great day.